kids love scooby-doo but there's a lot
of questionable aspects to the mystery
series but they might not catch until
after they've grown up he has the most
suspect stuff and scooby-doo shows that
only grown-ups pickup on scooby-doo is
so familiar that we all tend to open
look at central conceits
one of the main characters is a talking
dog but it's even more unbelievable than
a Great Dane who speaks and experiences
human emotions other reactions are the
people around him and we're saving this
for an emergency emergency shaggy Fred
Velma Daphne and the various criminals a
bust are never impressed or freaked out
by Scooby Scoobies human-like
intelligence and ability to speak should
probably make him a marvel of nature
science or both but everybody can versus
with Scooby like it's the most normal
thing in the world
talking dog aside the cast's of most
scooby-doo shows has led by the same for
humans of mystery Incorporated Fred
Jones Daphne Blake Velma Dinkley and
Norville shaggy Rogers together this
unlikely foursome travels the land in
their psychedelic van solving mysteries
and debunking supernatural phenomena
that much is obvious but what isn't
clear is just how old they're all
supposed to be it'd have to be at least
16 to drive that sweet van and making
them teens would put them closer to the
show's target demographic of children
plus the villains loved to call them
meddling kids but it also seems like
there must be at least in their 20s
since teenagers wouldn't likely be found
living unsupervised on the open road and
speaking of the open road why are they
out on the road in the first place of a
homeless or possibly fleeing something
ghastly since the show was originally
produced in the late 60s and early 70s
one possibility could have even been
that Fred or Shaggy was dodging the
Vietnam draft and Daphne and Velma just
went along for the ride works
[Music]
kids may not pick up on the candle after
in each episode of scooby-doo but adults
can't help but wonder what business a
laugh track has on an animated
children's show true the laughter may
help remind young viewers that despite
at spooky situations scooby-doo is
supposed to be a light-hearted comedy
but a laugh track suggests that the show
was filmed in front of a live studio
audience which is impossible with the
cartoon like scooby-doo then again in
keeping with the spirit of the show
maybe those laughs are coming from
ghosts or are parts of an evil plot
hatched by corrupt amusement park owner
while kids may not pick up on some of
the show's less than subtle stoner vibes
among certain adult viewers scooby-doo
cartoons have long been beloved due to
Shaggy and Scooby's telltale habits a
children's cartoon may not ever
explicitly state that its characters are
marijuana enthusiasts but the clues in
scooby-doo are bountiful enough for the
Mystery Machine doesn't exactly need a
legalize a bumper sticker to make the
theme clear for example Shaggy and
Scooby can sometimes be seen emerging
from a big smoke cloud
additionally the pair is obsessed with
food particularly junk food it's almost
as though these two giggling slackers
one of whom wears bell-bottom pants and
sports unkempt hair always have the
munchies which begs the question if
shaggy smokes marijuana with this dog is
that nuts animal abuse goal number one
for Shaggy and Scooby has always been to
eat as much as possible and the two
frequently care more about finding their
next meal and doing their job of solving
mysteries
but while the duo is constantly eating
adults may notice that they actually
have a few dietary restrictions in some
of Scooby Doo's more recent episodes
shaggy often expresses his desire for
veggie sandwiches and other substitutes
for typical fast food staples this is no
accident shaggy moved away from meat in
2002 at the request of the guy who
provided his voice
legendary disc jockey Casey Kasem was a
noted vegan and he wanted to use his
platform as shaggy to educate kids about
the benefits of a vegetarian diet
these are burgers we changed management
last week now we're organic vegan every
episode of scooby-doo seems to follow a
formula the gang drives through the
night comes across a potentially haunted
location and gets down to business
looking for clues then although it's
never a good idea to go off alone in a
dangerous place before humans inevitably
decide to split up and if things weren't
already scary enough Fred their
self-appointed leader always has to go
and make things even creepier
whenever the pairings are made Fred's
the one who decides who will go off with
whom invariably he pairs himself with
Daphne a subjectivist intense romantic
interest no matter what case her
investigating Fred never fails to get
Daphne alone with him in darkened rooms
under the guise of doing their jobs what
a creep adding a young energetic
character to revitalizer showed us
getting a little long in the tooth is a
well-known television tradition and one
that almost always fails miserably on
scooby-doo with this sort of cynical
attempt to boost ratings resulted in one
of the most universally loathed
characters in cartoon history
scrappy-doo a pint-sized version of
scooby scrappy was clearly supposed to
be cute but wound up just being annoying
although he's meant to serve as a
contrast to Scooby's laid-back
fraidy-cat energy
scrappy-doo comes across as aggressive
and perpetually angling for a fistfight
not only is he a character nobody wants
it or asked for
but adults may be concerned about
Scrappy's excessively violent tendencies
and the wonder whether he might even be
a bit disturbed have you ever noticed as
scooby-doo seems to take place in the
bizarre world of meteorological
anomalies where it's always dark and
seemingly cold all kids may not notice
that we rarely see the sunshine on the
mystery Incorporated crew adults may
question the persistent nighttime of the
extended scooby-doo universe
additionally the Mia omnipresent fog
suggests a perpetually cold climate as
does Fred's heavy-looking shirt and
Velma's choice to always wear a cozy
orange turtleneck sweater but Shaggy's
always in a t-shirt which begs the
question just what temperature is in
this world when it began scooby-doo is a
silly formulaic cartoon about a dog and
some young people encountering ghosts
which always turned out to be shady
business owners trying to scare people
off their property but starting in the
70s to mix things up writers and
animates
the mystery solvers interact with
various guest stars whose real-world
counterparts could be living dead or
even fictional for example in one
installment Scooby and his friends meets
Laurel and Hardy the famous comedy duo
those are actual people who lived but
both died long before the episode aired
on other occasions the scooby-doo crew
met Sonny and Cher Don Knotts Josie and
the Pussycats and Batman the presence of
some of those guest stars will suggest
that the scooby characters are real
since they interacted with actual living
humans but if some of those humans were
dead does that mean the Mystery Machine
is unstuck from time and is Batman real
sooo fiction and real life are
confusingly blurred making their reality
of scooby-doo a little tough to define
but young scooby-doo viewers it may not
be obvious that the episodes tend to
follow similar trajectories with Joy's
lead to a version of the same ending
what was thought to be a haunted
building turns out to not be so haunted
after all ghosts goblins spooks and
specters that scared the mystery
incorporated' crew so badly are revealed
to be some combination of projections
shadows sound effects and masked bad
guys in other words scooby-doo
constantly reiterates that all of that
spooky stuff isn't real and that there
is always a logical explanation for any
supernatural occurrence most of the time
the mystery the characters solve is
revealed to be the plot of a developer
or landowner hoping to scare people off
their land because greed is usually the
only real scary thing in the scooby-doo
universe yet every time the mystery
Incorporated team heads out on a new job
they seem to completely forget this
important facts and the dozens of normal
jerks have unmasked in the past every
episode features a gang overreacting to
what they think is a ghost or monster
leading to shaggy screaming then Shaggy
and Scooby and sometimes the entire gang
inevitably flee in terror either they
have terrible memories or their fear of
ghosts are so severe that they ignore
all logic which kind of makes you wonder
why they're in the supernatural
detective business to begin with based
on what happens during every single
mystery they've encountered one of them
ought to walk right up to the monster or
ghosts the first time they see them and
tear off that mask but that thought
never seems to occur to them but of
course if the characters actually
learned from their previous cases
there'd be no more show apart from
mowing lawns and selling lemonade most
kids don't worry too much about putting
cash in their pocket
grown-ups though are concerned with
earning a living to provide necessities
like food shelter and clothing
so naturally adults watching scooby-doo
might have some questions about how
business is conducted a mystery
Incorporated
at first glance mystery Incorporated
seems to be a legitimate operation with
the incorporated part of the name
indicating that the detective firm is
registered with an oversight agency and
pays taxes but despite the official
sounding name adult viewers may wonder
exactly how this company is able to
operate although money rarely changes
hands business still appears to be
booming at least enough for the firm to
afford a company car or in this case a
groovy van one wonders what sort of
waves are for humans earn and whether or
not mystery Incorporated offers health
vision and dental benefits in classic
episodes of scooby-doo the dedicated
detectives of mystery Incorporated
navigate through the many backroads and
country highways of America forever in
search of their next sleuthing gig but
if you look closely that straightforward
premise may have some dark undertones in
the world of scooby-doo all the
buildings seem to be falling apart and
the land has started with closed
amusement parks and long abandoned ghost
towns all of this coupled with Shaggy
sheer relief whenever he comes across
food suggests that these young
entrepreneurs are trying to get by in a
world that has taken a pretty
significant turn for the worse perhaps a
severe economic depression left the
country in shambles or some kind of
natural or man-made catastrophe from the
people to flee all those small towns a
show may be for kids but all the signs
seem to indicate that scooby-doo might
be a glimpse at life in a
post-apocalyptic and nightmare anyone
who's caused a few episodes of
scooby-doo over the past 50 years
probably recalls the words - its bouncy
memorable theme song the theme song
seems to imply that scooby-doo spends
most of the show being hard to locate
and that the mystery Incorporated team
is constantly searching for him so that
they can get to work but that's not
actually what the show is about at all
scooby-doo never disappears during the
episodes and TN Shaggy and never apart
for long sure Scooby may run away from
scary stuff but shaggy is always with
him making the song suggestion that
Scooby is constantly missing a real
mystery
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the Bell so you don't miss a single one